hi good morning my name is Eleftheria
but I know it can be a little bit
difficult we pronunciate it so you can
call me Ellie and I'm from Jen developer
and today I'm going to tell you my story
of what again after 100 days of code so
does anyone know the challenge 100 days
of code alright great almost two years
ago I was doing my internship in
Amsterdam and I knew that after my
internship I should go back to my
country which is Greece and find my
first developer job but I didn't have a
lot of skills since my portfolio wasn't
that good so I thought that I should do
something to develop myself and develop
my skills every morning
I read in the media platform a lot of
articles I liked doing that and one day
I read an article called 100 days of
code the challenge and it was written by
the creator of a challenge called 100
days of codes and he was explaining the
rules and the benefits of taking part in
it the rules like the rules were to code
for at least one hour every day and
should be outside from your nine-to-five
developer job and then post that code on
github uploaded there and share it on
Twitter and also follow people there
give them feedback and be happy with
what you're doing so my next step was
challenge accepted
let's do this and I started coding every
day for at least one hour I was trying
to find things that I liked maybe it was
something from my work that I wanted to
do get better or something completely
different like a new skill a new
language and then I would upload the
code on github every time every day and
share it on Twitter and also try to give
my feedback there the first couple of
days I was quite shy using Twitter and I
didn't really know how to do that so I
was just like like like every post but
then I was
was started connecting with people and
started leaving comments and people gave
me feedback and I thought that I'm doing
something nice and I'm getting better
and I should continue doing that so this
gave me motive a lot of people either
own emails or friends that I was telling
them about that I'm doing the challenge
were asking me how do you find where to
kotor I want to start also coding but I
don't know how can I do that for me
though there are a lot of great sources
and they're usually free which is nice
and you can learn a lot of stuff there
there are online educational platforms
like free code come that I used a lot
and udemy Udacity Coursera futurelearn
and a lot a lot more of course there is
YouTube that you can find courses for
all levels and this is always free and
online communities and here I'm
referring to Stack Overflow like we
wouldn't be there if it was on the Stack
Overflow and there are other coding
challenges I did there 100 days of code
but then of course there's 30 days there
decides our daily CSS images and all
these challenges gives you an email and
in this mail you can find a link or a
YouTube video or something and you can
fold it and also get better you can read
books and magazines like one of my
favorite books if you're the JavaScript
developer is the Lockean JavaScript I
think it's also well known and does
inspiration I can read blogs ROS forums
for all your favorites publications on
medium war on twitter and read read read
of course go to meetups and attending
conferences write this is a full mix of
everything and so now what did I learn
and what did I want it to learn the
first thing and the most basic thing if
you want to be front-end developer which
was my goal is to know the basics like
HTML CSS and JavaScript but it's not
only this then you have to develop so
it's like html5
is 3/5 bootstrap like spokes and all
these kind of beautiful things and then
a switch starts using the JavaScript
console more I mean I wanted to do that
for a long time but I didn't know how to
do it and I saw other developers that
were doing it but I was like okay I see
all these little pretty tabs there but I
don't know what exactly they are doing
but it's ok I can do it and then the
last thing that I wanted to learn was
maybe angularjs or another framework I
wasn't sure about it but I learned
angularjs and the data visualization
library and I learned the D 3GS now what
did I build one of the first things that
I built was I have a short animation
here all these images that you can see
are made with only CSS or is a CSS and
some HTML some of them are very very
simple and it can be done in less than
an hour but some of them are more
complicated so this was my first step
learn very good HTML and CSS and I built
50 of these images the next thing was
JavaScript and I started building some
parts of websites and used my first API
calls some of them were very simple and
not very good not very stylish but I
tried then I started getting into more
like games and quizzes
my first quizzes were also very very
simple only questions and then some
answers and discourse but as I was doing
their free code camp there were some
challenges there and one of them was the
Simon game in the tic-tac-toe game and I
started learning more and more how to
code better in JavaScript and build its
games then my next goal was to learn
angularjs and once again I started
building some small parts of websites
and they were very simple but for me it
was a big step because it was the first
time that I was building something and
people liked it I saw it in Twitter
right and
then I thought that I wanted to do also
something extra and that was learning a
data visualization and I chose the
library d3 GS and this is an example of
it and last but not least I build days
almost two months ago and it's a
screenshot for a game the game is called
game of life and this game took me one
or two days only to understand the rules
of how to play it so it was a big
procedure for me to learn firstly how to
played it and then how to code it but in
the end I learned a lot of things and I
think it's critical does anyone know the
game game of life it's very complicated
it's very complicated
ok so I didn't build all these things in
100 days of codes like as the challenge
said I continued building things after
this time so a lot of people ask me what
is my motivation and what inspires me
and for me it's always an urge to get
better and follow my dreams and my
dreams is getting better and have a good
job and also help others so there is
this quote from Tim Ferriss maybe some
of you can find it a little bit arrogant
but it says you are the average of the 5
people you're most associated with and I
totally believe this like here today
everyone is here because I guess he
wants or she wants to get better and
learn something more and learn something
cool and how can we do that we can
socialize and connect with others so I
think these quotes really represent what
we are doing now and maybe our dreams
and our goals and another quote I would
also like to encourage you to take part
in this challenge or learn something
more or develop a skill but it's like
I'm not telling you it's going to be
easy but I'm telling you it's going to
be worth it because after completing
this challenge and after learning all
these skills
I also get
socialized a lot more again followers on
Twitter I found a nice job and it wasn't
very difficult to find a job although
when I started I was very afraid that I
wouldn't be able to do anything so so
here I'm going to present some tips and
tricks it I believe will help you also
to do something great and the first of
them is setting your goals and
priorities right we can do anything we
don't have a specific clear goal in our
mind so set your goal and priorities and
[ __ ] straight with them another
important thing that I've also talked
about is fighting your motivation the
motivation can be different for everyone
maybe for some of them is just a
learning skill to impress their boss or
take a promotion or somebody else wants
to do a freelancing job to help their
family financially and also want to do
to have that new skill but motivation as
this image shows there can only get you
so far when you want to be at the top so
it's like when you begin to do something
you are yes I'm going to do that and I'm
going to kill that and everything will
be better
but after times passes like your energy
goes down down down so what you have to
do is be determined you have to be
determined as you have to say yes I'm
going to do it I'm going to build it I'm
going to make a new skill or something
yes and I really like this humans here
and I'm going to read it it says like
how do you program so well practice it
must be an interdict a gift from God
it's practice 11 understand how people
are so talented a mystery at its
practice so yes
it's practice you're not gifted or at
least I'm not gifted but I have
practiced a lot and then there is
another problem and I think that's
pretty much most of us have it and it's
time management we don't have the time
to build something to learn something or
do something cool that you like and for
me what held me
is first thing put your phone away set
it to silent set it to airplane mode
just don't be in the same room with it
alright then if you think like one hour
is a lot you can use the Pomodoro clock
the Pomodoro Technique sorry which
basically says that set a timer for 20
to 25 minutes then take a break for five
minutes and continue this for three
times and then voila you have your one
hour so the last thing is I keep it to
Julius or a calendar read of this thing
like a lot of times but I I didn't use
to do that in the end I started doing
starting Kubica color or to-do list it
doesn't have to be something complicated
for me the simple the better just write
something down and try to stick to it
and in the end of the day you can review
it and see all the great things that you
have accomplished so by doing this
challenge I against a lot of things like
I learned to be more optimistic and
grateful and connect with people I also
did a lot of other challenges like I
mentioned thirty days thirty sides and
eleven to believe in myself I learned on
top myself so much and of course I met a
lot of people with different backgrounds
and different inspirations most of them
emitted them via Twitter or me emails or
maybe Skype but it was great hearing
their stories and what they also want to
accomplish now would I recommend signing
up for a challenge like this and the
answer of course for me is yes if you
want to get better improve and learn
something do something for yourself and
yes you should totally do this some
again small cheeks and chips like track
your progress daily or weekly goals
don't get easily disappointed always
encourage each other and be kind to
others and secure to your goals so thank
you very much that was my presentation